whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up US Senator
Chuck Schumer whose latest crusade is
halting an inhalable caffeine product
called arrow shot arrow shot may become
the next club drug in Utah state
legislature Tim cosgrove who's pushing a
bill that would put Reiki practitioners
and other spiritual healers in jail for
one year unless they spend hundreds of
hours and thousands of dollars getting a
massage license never mind that this
isn't really massage and can be done
without even touching the client but
there can be only one nanny of the month
and this time it's Arizona State rep
Katie Hobbs who's sponsoring a bill that
would force advertisers to include
warnings alongside ads that airbrush
models young people need to realize that
there isn't a single product that can
make you look perfect and just having
that disclaimer and really help them
have a pop more positive self-image the
disclaimer would go like this push
production techniques were made to alter
the appearance in this advertisement
when using this product similar results
may not be achieved
activists are pushing for a similar
federal law and British regulators
already ban all kinds of ads they deem
deceptive or inappropriate including
this Levi's campaign which officials say
encourages children to play with
fireworks check back next month for more
examples of busybodies minding your own
business
you